this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron blue apron
is the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe delivery service in the country
blue aprons mission is to make
incredible home cooking accessible to
everyone
roasted chicken and fall vegetables with
cranberry and ginger compote seared
steak garlic butter with oven fries and
romaine salad doesn't just are the
offerings for November I'll talk more
about it later try out blue aprons
all-time customer favorites and get $30
off your first order with free shipping
by going to blue apron home slash
Congrats
this episode is also brought to you by
the cash out
it seems the babies are switching to the
cash app and it's the number one finance
app in the App Store
and I use it and I switched over and
it's super easy they've introduced the
cash card BAM it's a new black debit
card that you can design yourself via
the app allowing you to use the cash
that you keep in the app anywhere you
want plus it's the best way to pay
people back yeah so so you got a switch
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now the [ __ ] is up it's episode
41 and this is the beginning of it it's
times gonna pass we're gonna get in the
middle of the episode and after that the
episodes gonna be over before you know
it
now I know chronologically that makes so
much sense but my point is some of you
guys wait for this every week and it's
now so enjoy it don't take it for
granted and laugh laugh loud if you want
or if not get angry or or if not just
feel good or decide that this is the
last time that you're ever gonna listen
to it because you hate me but either way
this is the moment but this episode
honestly is actually really brought to
you by do you know what it's actually
really brought to you by my [ __ ] app
I got a new app you just go to the App
Store and type in Chris D'Elia and and
that's the [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] right there this is to
streamline us as a cult and to make sure
we have a place to discuss ideas and you
can post stuff about the podcast you can
post stuff about my stand-up you can
post stuff whatever you want but it's my
app you type it into the App Store chris
d'elia it comes up and you download it
and that's - and you know what that is
that's to help me back up the [ __ ]
Brinks truck dude these instagrams these
[ __ ] Twitter's they're all making
money off of us I'm making money now off
of me bro I see Diddy I see Kevin Hart I
see all these [ __ ] guys do it it's
time for [ __ ] daddy to get this cult
going and really make some [ __ ]
scrilla do you understand and you're
gonna help with that so uh anyway it's
[ __ ] episode 41 so download the app
and and and let's have some fun my
babies I just recorded a video saying
we're going we're gonna bout to record
for the episode 41
I'm gonna give you exclusiveness I'm
gonna give you behind the scenes BTS as
a [ __ ] hooker on Instagram would
hashtag it's all good
but you know if you were a hooker on
Instagram get hashtag BTS because that's
what a lot of now of course real models
do it now of course real models do it
now I don't want to feel the fierce
backlash of the Instagram community even
though won't cuz don't matter that much
don't matter that much but you know
hookers also post BTS when nobody
shootin anything of them and they're
just taking a [ __ ] selfie or a shot
in the mirror with their [ __ ] body
looking like the men in black [ __ ]
guys that destroy the kitchen you know
those little animals sometimes those
[ __ ] models look like the the little
animal because they're doing like some
curvy
[ __ ] thing with their body they look
at those little aliens that are
destroyed the kitchen and men in black
they do hey you look like that and
you're taking a picture of a [ __ ] pic
of yourself in the mirror e hooker you
take cash for [ __ ] you take cash for
[ __ ] you take racks and stacks for
getting the dick I'm feeling good man
and I'm wearing a [ __ ] pink shirt and
you can see it if you're looking at the
video podcast and I'm wearing pink shoes
dude and I don't give a [ __ ] and I
almost didn't because I don't like to do
matchy-matchy my mom got it in my head
when I was younger dude she's like I
don't like when you match your shoes
with your shirt and it [ __ ] me up man
and it [ __ ] me up she also used to say
either you're gonna get sick she used to
say that every [ __ ] goddamn night of
my life
she'd say either you're gonna get sick
and it took me about thirty four three
years
33 34 years to realize oh wait a minute
if I skip a meal it doesn't mean I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] bird flow it
doesn't mean I'm gonna get a common cold
it really took some man it really this
[ __ ] really damages you you know I mean
that's not even a bad thing like I had a
great life coming up but my mom be like
either you're gonna get sick with a
[ __ ] plate of chicken staring at me
in New Jersey either you're gonna get
sick and my little kid you say that
enough - you said three times to a kid
he's [ __ ] up she would say at AE every
night and I'd eat it or cuz I don't want
to get sick you know hey mom's stop
[ __ ] up your son's you can't no
matter what we [ __ ] up that's the thing
that's why there's [ __ ] SoundCloud
rappers now it just gets worse and worse
and worse and before you know it you got
[ __ ] guys with six is tattooed on his
goddamn eyeball that's what happens man
just came from a [ __ ] coffee shop and
there's a guy there I never [ __ ]
talked about this did I there's a
there's a guy there Brian Collins
calling me right now
look at that [ __ ] Brian Collins
calling me
actually now I shouldn't because who
knows what the [ __ ] he's gonna say I
almost put on speaker and he'd be like
what's up you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know I picked up and hung up on him
[ __ ] him you know but anyway um so
anyway what was I gonna say oh yeah so
there's this guy who teaches English at
this coffee shop I go to he teaches
English to [ __ ] people who want to
learn English and it's cool and he's
there all day and it's you know it's
almost it's almost like you should rent
out space super nice guy but he says hi
to everybody that comes in the coffee
shop because he knows everybody and he
knows me
I don't know him of course and I saw him
today and it was like [ __ ] 11 a.m.
and you know he knows people are coming
in when he comes in he's he's one of
those guys that just talks so loud to
people there's like there's like 23
people in the coffee shop and he'll just
be like hey how's your day going and
this girl's like oh you know pretty good
you eating a banana she's like yep and
he's like she's like I'm trying to talk
with my mouth full but huh oh yeah and
everyone everyone here's what's up with
these loud talkers dude talk quieter
everyone can hear everyone can [ __ ]
hear we can all hear we got ears
um but uh so I'm like I got to leave and
I'm trying to not make eye contact with
him because I don't really have much
time I don't want to [ __ ] saw him
well I walk over to the trash can to
throw some away and he says hey man I
say uh what's going on and I talk
quieter when someone talks loud to me I
do it quieter so I because I want them
to know how goddamn loud they're talking
it's like the scene from [ __ ] heat
when Al Pacino was like oh boy oh oh
we're gonna take guns oh boy and Robert
DeNiro just like you know what I mean
and Al Pacino is like [ __ ] I'm
killing it oh boy I'm killing it I'm
killing it and then Robert Nero's like
not really
you really realize what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] a Pacino's being when [ __ ]
Robert you know comes in and does that
right so I'm [ __ ] doing the Robert De
Niro to his Al Pacino and he's just like
so he says uh how's the country because
you know he knows I tore and [ __ ] which
and I'm and in my head I almost say if
it was a normal guy that talked not loud
I'd be like well actually I was at it
out of the country for about three weeks
I was in Australia but I don't want to
so I just say oh it's good [ __ ] man it's
good and he says oh great and then I
leave and it's embarrassing cuz like now
everybody knows in there that I I'm all
around the country and they know my
business and I don't really care if
people know my business at the coffee
shop I don't give a [ __ ] but it's just
like is that what are we doing a play
you know I mean we'll be doing a [ __ ]
play and everyone's an audience member
hey man all those shoes look comfortable
he'll be like that oh yeah they are yeah
what are they and now I got to [ __ ]
tell everybody oh they're they're ultra
boosts you know yadda yadda and now
everybody knows I [ __ ] you know what
I mean ordered ultra boost online or
some [ __ ] that's just embarrassing I get
I get like here's the thing
I um I I never get like embarrassed
really because I always said like when
you bomb in front of Life 400 people
which I've done before like that's the
worst part of embarrassment that that's
like there's nothing more embarrassing
than that like literally you can walk
into a classroom in high school with
your dick out by mistake and you avin if
you have a little [ __ ] penis that has
a little bit of discoloration on it it's
less embarrassing than [ __ ] bombing
in front of 400 people so I've done that
that's the scariest thing what Oh
so what's what what's less well well now
I'm gonna talk to a girl and fail who
gives a flying [ __ ] [ __ ] I've bombed in
front of 400 people at the Irvine improv
after Siddiqui fuller went on and
murdered so so I [ __ ] went on and so
I didn't go on so so I get him I I don't
get embarrassed I don't get embarrassed
and I don't get nervous really because
it's hard for comedians to get nervous
check Siddiqui folder out by the way
he's funny as a [ __ ] great guy but uh
but uh there's a few times I do get a
little weird when I have I have to have
a loud conversation with somebody and
there's other people around um and but
here's another thing that I I actually
wrote this down because I I don't know
about this
here look so I feel like I just got over
this by the way I used to feel like
sometimes I feel [ __ ] embarrassed and
like a [ __ ] at restaurants and I wonder
if you guys feel this way too or if this
is just a me thing when I'm when I have
to order food I feel [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
not not like a mean [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
like insecure [ __ ] when I when I win it
by the way whenever I say [ __ ] I mean
insecure I don't mean like you know but
I feel like a [ __ ] whenever I have to
order a food from a restaurant because
and this is so weird because especially
if it's like a [ __ ] rootin tootin
cobb salad
because they made it first of all I
won't say that if I'm at the [ __ ]
Denny's and it says moons over my hammy
and that's what I want
I grab the menu and I look at the waiter
and I say that's what I want and I and
if there's no picture I say this and I
and they have to read it because I'm not
[ __ ] going to your establishment and
saying moons over my hammy okay I'll say
it here to let you know that we don't
stand for that in the congratulations
cult but dude you're gonna you're gonna
make me
just cuz I'm hungry sit down at your
restaurant and say some cute [ __ ]
like moons over my hammy uh-uh
dude I ain't saying it now I hate to say
it like this but dude I ain't sayin it
do it I ain't sayin it
I'm no [ __ ] CUDA dude you're not
getting me all lost up in the sauce do
it no [ __ ] way
okay so um oh by the way not ordering
moons over my hammy cuz don't want
cancer okay the reason is why because I
don't want a heart attack
oh and they come in it for sure no doubt
in denny's they [ __ ] jerk-off in the
food you're telling me that nobody's
ever jerked off and [ __ ] come in the
food at Denny's full of [ __ ] short-order
chefs do it all the time and you know
they do
hey one of by the way don't ever send
some [ __ ] back on a short-order chef
there's no [ __ ] way they spit and
come in it no doubt there's no [ __ ]
doubt if you're in a nice rack classy
restaurant cool but if you're out some
[ __ ] thing like the the Greenwich
[ __ ] diner or something in new in New
York they'll come in your [ __ ] on
your plate no doubt
yeah I never send food back when it
looks like a janky-ass place but uh I
feel like a [ __ ] when I have to say
especially I used to I just got over
this at at the edge sushi when I sit at
the bar and I'm alone and I'm like yeah
can I get two salmon sushi I feel like a
[ __ ] even saying it now I don't know
why yeah can I get two I would like to
get two orders of the salmon sushi and I
hate here's the thing to men when you go
get sushi every time you order two
orders of the salmon [ __ ] sushi or
whatever they would say so that's a two
piece order to to order two orders
that's a Ford yeah I know two comes in
the [ __ ] 1 2 P so to order to order
ok so good and it's because all these
[ __ ] people that [ __ ] it up yeah let
me get a two
and then for calm and then they're like
oh I ordered two and you're like yeah
but two coming to look at the [ __ ]
menu they have pictures of the goddamn
thing oh I just wanted to it's 18 the
door loaders how expensive is sushi you
know what the [ __ ]
fish is expensive man but I do I feel
like a [ __ ] when I ever I have to order
some [ __ ] I don't really feel like a
[ __ ] whenever I have to order something
on like a cafe but I do when I feel when
I when I have to [ __ ] go at like a
like a little bit of nicer restaurant I
don't know what the [ __ ] that is dude
it's weird but anyway this guy was
talking about talking louder and [ __ ]
[Music]
surround about but goddamn he was just
talking loud what is up with that people
that just [ __ ] talk loud sometimes i
straight-up tell him I said hey man you
talking too loud bro I'm right here it's
all good I tried to do it in a disarming
way you know um I was at this [ __ ]
other coffee shop the other day and I
went to go back out of this space it was
after they were closed and I went to go
back out of the space and I almost hit
the [ __ ] chain that they blocked a
parking lot off with which is like why
you know why what was someone's gonna
park there after hours who gives a [ __ ]
who cares you're gonna put a chain
across your parking lot fruit for what
oh cool now in Acura can't park there
oh hey guys what if the [ __ ] Acura
part to there for three hours I'm
[ __ ] annoyed with myself right now
talking about that I don't if I if I was
listening to me right now the podcast I
turn it off at
point but no the and I almost hit it and
I've decided in my head in my fantasy
you ever do this [ __ ] in my fantasy I
hit it got mad because I was still there
at the at the coffee shop so in my head
they shouldn't have put the chain over
there yet because I was still in the
establishment and then because the other
exit didn't have the chain on it and
they wanted everyone to leave that chain
that way but in my head I hit it and my
fantasy and I parked this car right
where it was where I hit it and walked
back in and I yelled at them and I said
I'm still in the [ __ ] parking lot why
the [ __ ] would you put the chain on
obviously I might back up and hit it
what is up with you [ __ ] and
then I and then I like felt good that in
my fantasy III I stood up for myself
even though none of it happened you know
I did a whole Larry David episode in my
head and even though it didn't happen I
felt vindicated I drove home like yeah
that'll [ __ ] teach them didn't happen
you guys do that [ __ ] - I know you do
how [ __ ] crazy is that the [ __ ] you
think of you ever think of [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] like that and then you're like oh
god this is [ __ ] up
like I'll I'll straight-up think
sometimes I'm hanging out with somebody
and I'll think what happens if I just
stabbed them up their [ __ ] neck what
would happen they it would be all
[ __ ] goofy and real you know just
like they'd make that noise you know and
then they'd fall down dead and I'd be a
[ __ ] criminal I'd be a [ __ ]
criminal and then I'd have to run or
turn myself in if I just [ __ ] found
it a sharp fence and then well go go and
just [ __ ] talk about gargle gargle
dude
and then just bleeding all over their
[ __ ] Massimo shirt or sometimes I
[ __ ] I mean I here's the thing I
think about that [ __ ] I do I don't care
and and and and I think a lot of you
guys do too
one time I was hanging out at [ __ ] in
some Mexican restaurant with my friend
Morgan boys Aki dude I was always for
the friends with the [ __ ] weirdest
kids man when I was in high school my
mom will be like how come you can't hang
out with people who have parents I can
hang out with Morgan Joy's Aki was his
Japanese the only [ __ ] Japanese kid
by the way the only Asian kid in my
[ __ ] high school that got DS all
Asians got a pluses they got new letters
whatever is above the a zap they got the
letter zap that was that's before a
that's how good they were and I was
friends with the only [ __ ] Asian guy
that got DS Morgan toys Aki and his mom
will be like every time I caught you say
much much here and I say hey is Morgan
there Oh Morgan and a home Morgan out
here Morgan and not here okay cause here
dude and one time we watched we were an
over [ __ ] Morgan's house and we
watched faces of death on VHS do it
remember that [ __ ] faces of death
remember that [ __ ] thing where they
would be like some in some other
countries people eat live monkeys and
they would put a [ __ ] monkey in a in
a in a [ __ ] device and like the
people who are at the place to eat would
just bash the monkey's head in until it
died and then eat the monkey brains and
then some guy just it would just show
people dying where could you get you had
to get it like a [ __ ] you couldn't
get it a blockbuster obviously but it's
called faces of death and would have
videos of real bugs before the internet
and they'd have like you get have to get
it at some place called like [ __ ]
Odyssey video you know or like extreme
some and you'd be like do you have faces
of death and they would always [ __ ]
say no but we have traces of death there
was a ripoff traces of death there was
faces of death which is the one and then
they'd [ __ ] rip it they had traces of
death how could you have [ __ ] trace
dude if there's a thing called faces of
death and it's popular how could you
have a [ __ ] thing called traces of
death what if
[ __ ] dick all for the cash man so we
would do it some so I would [ __ ] so
one time I was our Mexican restaurant so
anyway my mom couldn't be friends with a
[ __ ] Japanese lady who couldn't speak
English obviously there's another kid
Michael whose dad was Greek as [ __ ] dude
I don't even remember Michael's last
name but his dad was Greek his [ __ ] and
one time I said Oh mom there's my friend
cuz we just moved from New Jersey and I
was like oh mom there's my friend
Michael and we were at the [ __ ] pick
and save parking lot and him and I waved
that my mom waved the Michael and the
dad was in the car and he was all
rushing in he was oh no he was Russian
and he was like hello hello and he
almost [ __ ] hit the goddamn poles
that they have for no reason in the
parking structures why are there [ __ ]
poles for no reason sometimes in parking
structures just for us to hit him and
[ __ ] anyway you almost hit the thing and
he had to stop and my mom [ __ ]
laughed so hard dude and then she told
me either I'm gonna get sick my son is
named Michael even though it's obviously
Mikael but we moved to Southern
California even though it is Mikael he
it is Michael now and so he almost
[ __ ] crashed into the yellow pole at
[ __ ] pick and save he's probably dead
now you know it's [ __ ] 25 years later
he's [ __ ] dead you ever think about
that [ __ ] [ __ ] died you're
watching movies in the 80s and somebody
60 in the in a movie in the 80s and
you're like guy that [ __ ] dead
now this doesn't get stabbed in the
[ __ ] neck go go go go go go go and
just drop down [ __ ] dead [ __ ] that is
a [ __ ] door knob you hear that [ __ ]
crack in my neck cuz it's real so um so
anyway so Morgan so anyway one time I
was it by the way man that's one of
those names Morgan it's like dude you're
male or female Morgan
you have a [ __ ] name your male or
female [ __ ] male or female did pick
the name [ __ ] Kent okay if your name
is gonna be Morgan if you think about
naming your kid Morgan as a guy named um
Kent
alright if you're thinking about naming
a kid Morgan as a girl named her [ __ ]
Mary do you understand Kent or Mary not
Morgan anyway so one time I took one of
these fantasies for real man I wanted to
do it I put a bunch of salt in my
[ __ ] hands in my hand and I said to
Morgan oh man there's so many [ __ ]
stories about Morgan did so I said hey
man you want to feel my ninja dust and
he said what the [ __ ] is that I said he
would always work every time he said
what the he would always run it together
what the [ __ ] is that
and I'd say you want to feel my ninja
dust he's oh oh I don't know what the
[ __ ] that is what the [ __ ] is that
and I said well do you want it's yes or
no dude if you don't want if you've
[ __ ] no feel my ninja dust then just
say no and we'll drop it and we won't
talk about the ninja just ever ever
again but he was too curious he that's
the thing man curiosity will [ __ ] get
you I said you either want to know what
it is you don't and he said well no you
know
sure yeah his curiosity got the best of
him and I took the salt and I [ __ ] I
throw right at his face in a 1 in his
eyes and that was a shitty thing to do
and he goes like this oh look is the
begins at work is that what the book is
it he [ __ ] was believing his eyes and
and I was laughing dude I was laughing
like a [ __ ] and I said its salt
man don't worry about it think it was
dude [ __ ] cumin what do think it was
ninja dust oh because it was it and then
one time I played soccer and we were on
the same team dude we were [ __ ]
horrible he he was goalie he was goalie
and I was [ __ ] defense cuz obviously
I was an offense because I [ __ ]
sucked cuz soccer sucks ok run around
and never stop no but it's soccer see ya
hey by shin pads no never would I
[ __ ] ever do an event where I had to
block my shins from getting hurt see ya
so I knew about bicycle kicks and I
thought those things were the [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude bicycle kicks bro land on your
back and [ __ ] kick the ball out of
trouble that's got my name written all
over it dude
I don't give a [ __ ] what I did in soccer
I was gonna do bicycle kicks that was
gonna be my specialty bro you know in
video games when you [ __ ] have to
make your team or whatever or it's a
racecar game and you're like well this
car is good at accelerating but the
traction is shitty and it's so fast but
the [ __ ] the the the the the the
other thing is good or the [ __ ]
wheels are great or whatever the [ __ ] I
always wear people pick the [ __ ] one
that's best at all of them the average
one that's best cuz you can't get good
at everything unless you're like I level
100 which is [ __ ] but you'd have to
get picked the one that's like good at
like [ __ ] accelerating or good at
like traction [ __ ] that I didn't I
didn't pick the one that was at the best
at it you know average the best I picked
the one that always had warm that was
bonkers good at something like the
acceleration and then I just [ __ ]
killer than the acceleration and then
losing long run and then they say this
game sucks so uh [ __ ] I don't know what
I was talking about what oh yeah
so the [ __ ] bicycle I was like dude
I'm gonna be horrible at defense offense
stamina and everything but bicycle kicks
were gonna be my [ __ ] so I was like
whenever I see a ball coming hi I'm
going upside the [ __ ] down and bicycle
kicking it out of trouble okay now I
play defense
alright so sure enough games in this is
into the season I remember we were the
Green Team haywire so soccer Morgan was
the only other guy that I knew on the
team and he was and he was the goalie so
it was me and [ __ ] Morgan joy sake
chilling them the defense all the time
getting scored on okay now we weren't a
very good team and the reason why is
because me and Morgan died sake were on
it if you got two of us on your team
it's probably gonna be bad
okay unless you got [ __ ] Pele on it
too
but here comes the ball high and I and
and it's a nama and I'm and it and it's
coming and I don't want it to get I
don't want to get scored on even though
I secretly don't give a [ __ ] but not
secretly also the coach knew but because
that's why I [ __ ] was defense he had
to put me in so the ball came high and
here it comes my chance to [ __ ]
bicycle kick it so here daddy goes
[ __ ] upside down and I'm gonna go
kick it and I connect and Morgan's there
too and he's like well I'll just grab it
he's like no no Chris all that work
you're doing all the work you're doing
and I kicked it and sure enough by
mistake I [ __ ] kicked it right into
our goal no no no what are we doing and
we [ __ ] and I scored on our team and
the other team got the point and I don't
give a [ __ ] and I didn't give a [ __ ]
then either I went oh [ __ ] what were you
doing no Chris no Dan dude
Morgan doesn't govern he looks against
his dad dude he's turning into a stud oh
is that his sister his mom oh that's his
mom Wow I mean of course they got
pictures with [ __ ] Hawaiian shirts
and leis on I feel like that's an Asian
family thing to do that's his brother oh
wow
taking me back I don't know if we should
show these pics on the on the podcast
but it's [ __ ] crazy how uh to see
those guys again
sweating like a [ __ ] guys so I
like a [ __ ] some reason I didn't
put airs ever in some podcasts room all
right guys lifts lifts knows that their
drivers are what keep them moving so
they do everything they can to make sure
their drivers are happy on every trip
it's a simple formula happy drivers
means happy cut passengers maybe that's
why nine out of ten lift rides get a
perfect five-star rating you can earn
hundreds of dollars a week plus tips you
want to earn money more money
drive more it's never been easier to
give yourself a raise lift was the first
ride share platform with tipping built
right into the app you keep 100% of the
tips and they add up fast baby's drivers
have been paid over 200 million dollars
since the feature was first introduced
imagine that all in your pocket 200
million dollars you can do whatever you
want Express pay lets you get paid
almost instantly instead of waiting for
weeks so join the ride-sharing company
that believes in treating its people
better go to lifts calm / Congrats today
and get a $500 new driver bonus that's
lift calm / Congrats
lift calm / Congrats limited time only
terms apply hey
do it and be cool when they pick you up
because they got cool colors that help
you pick out which one which one you
know is yours it's pink oh that's got a
pink thing on it I'll just hop in that
one blue apron
I've been eating blue day blue apron man
blue apron is great food
it really is it's the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country and maybe that's why it's
so good because fresh ingredients blue
aprons mission is to make incredible
home cooking accessible to everyone it's
easy they give you the ingredients and
they just show up and you do exactly
what it says and then you put it in
now you like crispy wild Alaskan Pollock
and garlic mashed potatoes and potatoes
with roasted broccoli and tartar sauce
III didn't even know but guess what I do
I ate the crispy wild Alaskan Pollock
and it was good in my mouth
cheesy broccoli baked pasta with crispy
time breadcrumbs yeah seared steaks and
garlic butter with oven fries and
romaine salad yeah
roasted chicken and fall vegetables with
cranberry and ginger compote yeah check
out this week's menu and get $30 off
your first order with free shipping by
going to blue apron dot-com slash
Congrats
you will love how good it feels and
taste to create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue apron so don't wait
that's blue apron dot-com / Congrats
blue apron a better way to cook tacos
sweating my [ __ ] balls off guys I'm
sweating my [ __ ] balls off um I've
been killing it at the gym meant just
[ __ ] working hard hey dude I've
joined I've been a lot in a lot of gyms
and [ __ ] in my life well not a lot
five six but I noticed something man
people don't [ __ ] workout hard I go
to the gym I [ __ ] work hard I I'm
pretty much it's very rare where there's
two minutes that I'm not doing something
[ __ ] are walking around texting
sitting on machines farting and dilly
dallying around the [ __ ] out of here
dude I don't understand that and I don't
understand people that are just so
jacked staring at themselves in the
mirror all the time just [ __ ] work
out and go home you got mirrors at home
I actually think that guys who work out
so much and are so [ __ ] fit and look
like bodybuilders I think all of those
guys have
the guy because they are you can't be
looking at your body and love the male
physique that much even if it's yours
without thinking I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
gonna without being sexually attracted
to it also I think all those guys have
[ __ ] each other bodybuilding is so
weird now at a professional level
professional level it's a little less
weird because at least you're [ __ ]
that your job these guys get paid
nothing though if you get paid a million
dollars as a bodybuilder that's insane
but if you're just a guy who like
recreationally pumps iron and you're so
big you're oh you're so weird dude
you're so weird
um how about how [ __ ] stupid some of
these routines are like some guys will
be doing robotic movements while he's
[ __ ] look at this planet vids calm
you know Russian bald bodybuilder looks
like robot no he doesn't what is he
doing dude what is he doing he made this
up at home you know I've seen this
before actually whatever at least leave
some [ __ ] shedding some some salty
weight some salt water what I said my
producer says gross dude on fire so
anyway uh get my app dude you know get
my [ __ ] app I don't give a [ __ ] get
my [ __ ] app dude I'm [ __ ] sweating
like a [ __ ] get my app you know
I'm lazy with this [ __ ] right now get it
I'm still
you know what I was thinking about the
other day yeah give me that towel what
is that is that what is it what's on it
you know I mean what is this yeah here
what is yours
Oh got it here right here did Terry yet
terry cloth yeah you get at my [ __ ]
website for the gym terry cloth I got my
terry cloth yeah ah oh yeah dude that
feels good dude how cool [ __ ] it you
know whatever you here in Phoenix so
much better dude so uh yeah it's [ __ ]
uh what 84 degrees in here or if you're
doing it's in Celsius 30 why is that man
why is America the only one that is like
will do Fahrenheit we'll make our own
[ __ ] that's so annoying dude then we
travel to [ __ ] somewhere else in your
land they're like oh it's 30 degrees and
you're like what no it's not I'm [ __ ]
hard yeah that's uh that's hot it's hot
mate
really yeah it's 30 degrees sometimes it
gets up to 40 degrees so knows that
gives up to 40 degrees near the light
really yeah sometimes it gets up to 40
degrees and he'll light that's freezing
that's not it's like 100 degrees for ye
unrevealed to gravy so uh yeah but
anyway I don't know why they would do
that America is such a [ __ ] America has
got such a [ __ ] you attitude you know or
they're just like now we'll do it our
own way like the metric system like just
do that like I'm in Australian people
are like yeah yeah oh I like knowing two
kilos oh the [ __ ] that means
the [ __ ] does that mean I have no clue
teach it in school they teach it in
school then they don't teach you the
other [ __ ]
I don't know um I'm gonna [ __ ] do
these other ads here ha stamps.com
these days you can get practically
everything on demand like our podcast
listen whenever you want when it's
convenient for you so why you still
going to the post office dude hey are
you in 1991
why are you dealing with their limited
hours get stamps at 3:00 a.m. when you
can get postage on demand with stamps
calm what are you doing going to the
post office
stamps calm anything you can do at the
post office you can do right now at your
desk with stamps calm my producer uses
it to mail out our elder certificates
and pins thanks dance calm
unlike the post office stamps calm never
closes right now use my name congrats
for this special offer four week trial
hey what's what it's what he wrote right
now use my name Congrats
it's what my producer wrote one fire
four week trial includes postage and a
digital scale don't wait go to stamps
calm before you do anything else click
on the radio microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in congrats that
stamps calm click the microphone enter
congrats stamps calm never go to the
post office again so you got to do is it
is um add my name Congrats Congrats
D'Elia Square cash now these guys have
been [ __ ] with us since the beginning
it seems the babies are switching to the
cash app and it's the number one finance
app in the App Store I use it it's cool
it's awesome it's it's green and [ __ ] I
like it maybe it's because it's the best
way to pay people back friends family
coworkers and dare I say even Kudus if
you go into the coachella [ __ ] and you
bought tickets for everybody or somebody
bought tickets for you you can pay a
CUDA back for your ticket it's never
been easy you download the square it's
never been this easy download the square
cash app link your debit or credit card
selected amount to send and type in a
friend's phone number or email address
to complete the payment
they get a notification they just
receive the money that's it no gimmicks
I did it with my buddy who I get shoes
from square cash is better than the
other guys it doesn't list your [ __ ]
stuff in a feed hey I don't want people
to know when I'm buying hair products
cash card is cool it's a black debit
card that you can design yourself via
the app here is mine and just robbed me
blind cuz now on the video app you can
see it cash card allows you to use the
cash that you keep directly in the via
the cash but directly via the cash app
laser at your card your artistic laser
at your card if your artistic
personalized it'll be delivered directly
to you for free download the free cash
app for iOS or Android now babies what
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] Yelp that's what I want to know
I go on Yelp but I want to know who
signs in on Yelp who [ __ ] leaves a
review on Yelp
you know what you know who you know who
really you know who relieves a review on
Yelp a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's who you cannot leave a review on
Yelp without being a [ __ ] [ __ ] to
sign in leave a comment or a review to a
picture frame shop and rate them three
stars and write how good the experience
was except for here were the
shortcomings and this is why it's three
stars not four or five or whatever
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
do you understand and we can all agree
on that and you have to understand that
if that's what you're doing you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then that's okay
but dude there are people out there that
spend time yelping Yelp reviewing donut
shops Ian's [ __ ] your Nassau spree
conch now look it's free conch you can
sign in to you it's free conch you can
write a review free conch you can post
in a review
however you
[ __ ] let me repeat that it's free
conch you can sign in on Yelp it's free
conch you can write a review on Yelp
it's free conch you can post the review
on Yelp however if you do Yan [ __ ]
now my producer coughed in the middle of
me doing that one fire because he can
hear it in the background but it's okay
you ness hey I didn't like these donuts
to get the sprinkled ones though
honestly it's the only reason for going
there two stars
you complete [ __ ]
why is your nose facing me turn round
take this dick turn round feel this
discomfort I don't want to [ __ ] you but
you don't want me to and that's what
should deserve probably not the best
[ __ ] joke to make now in today's
climate but you know what dude been
saying it since the [ __ ] beginning of
the podcast not changing because of
society how's that it's free conch do
what one so yeah boy it's [ __ ]
sweating the balls off here in the
[ __ ] congratulations studio sweatin
my balls huh yep [ __ ] I think it makes
the podcast better cuz I get all the
[ __ ] loosey-goosey cuz it's what my
balls off it was [ __ ] cold I don't
have a be so loosey-goosey okay
let's [ __ ] name these elders do it
okay it's about time we name these
[ __ ] elders these guys have been
[ __ ] killing it
we're naming these new elders these guys
nobody has been [ __ ] done done done
these guys have done these guys spend
man-hours
it's a sexist to call the man-hours when
female can work man-hours as well but
these guys put man-hours into this
[ __ ] Twitter account
they made the true baby's Twitter
account these are the new elders four of
them Sam link at Sam link Joey Scott at
Joey Scott Chris at Chris Crownover
underscore Craig at Craig Jones jr. at
the true babies that's who these guys
are
they made the true baby's Twitter
account which is already [ __ ] great
that they do it they make amazing
original content based on the show all
the time I retweet it it's [ __ ]
hilarious dude i watch his [ __ ] my how
they did a black panther preview a
pre-trail ur and then they did the whole
wendy's one about how we're coming for
them and it's a little scary but it's
definitely a joke but it's [ __ ]
hilarious
they make us laugh all that [ __ ] time
really me and my producer one fire in
one fire too but they couldn't be more
deserving of an eldership so their
elders now we just had to wait till we
caught up we wanted to give it to him
for a while
well DM you guys true babies with the
details to get your PIN and certificate
we're gonna send four of them and and so
that's that's cool oh and you know what
we also want to give a shout-out to mr.
green at green hip hop who made our
theme music he's an honorary elder so I
didn't want to forget that I keep
meaning to say that but congratulations
the true baby's Twitter account and we
were all through babies if you're doing
you know they're not only you they made
the account but but we're all sure we're
all for babies if you listen to the
podcast and if you guys are [ __ ]
listen listen to the podcast and spread
the word but they even made the last one
they made about the [ __ ] uh Wendy's
thing they even got like I feel like
they outsource the videos they asked
another elder to get a video she's in
anyway chairs are really good for them
you could tell these chairs are really
good for your back huh
these [ __ ] orange Salaam be asked
chairs um I'm gonna look up at these
[ __ ] the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week I know I put some here
uh okay now I have full bars here but
it's not happening okay this is this is
it this is it this is it it's great it's
a workout guy he's flexing real hard bad
lighting gym he's got a hat on I don't
like when people workout with baseball
hats on - that pisses me off it's like
what the [ __ ]
take it off you need to look like a
Broadway what I need to look cool this
is what it says I believe that Fitness
in itself can be viewed the same as that
of religion first of all it's so
annoying that he says that of religion
like we like just talk the way you talk
why do people got to be so dramatic they
think they got something to say I
believe that Fitness in itself like you
could just say I believe I think Fitness
is like religion right why is this
[ __ ] guy saying I believe that
Fitness in itself can be viewed the same
as that of religion he's never said a
sentence like this before in his life
but he's writing it like that because
you think he's got a platform and you
know what he does which is annoying now
granted he's probably only got how many
followers he's got seven um not even
seven hundred followers but it's like
dude if you were talking to the room 700
people has a lot of people like religion
now here comes the awful analogies like
religion it can be depicted in both a
positive and negative light I mean I
guess you know who really thinks of
working out as negative nobody
therefore strong analogy already those
that don't underst
and an often mock or disregarded
entirely who [ __ ] disregards working
out like I understand if you don't want
to do it but who's like nah nobody [ __ ]
nobody's nah some feel they need it but
are not ready to fully commit the time
okay both communities in a way have
saved people from depression suicide
drug alcohol addictions etc sure yet
that often goes unnoticed okay I guess
you're not really in there and I go
unnoticed now the reality is you can
believe in whatever you want at the end
of the day I want now here's where he
makes it about him i 100% guarantee I
will still wake up before 5:00 a.m.
tomorrow plug my headphones in and
practice my religion he means work out
obviously whenever I read something like
that in my head and sometimes out loud I
go like this what's he doing I'll go
come on who are these [ __ ] people
think they are Gandhi hey man did you
walk around in the desert for years no
you just have a car and drive to the gym
hey see ya see ya
that's the most
Instagram post of the week I don't know
when the [ __ ] but uh yeah Wow
my dogs keep throwing up what's the deal
with that
my dog took a [ __ ] liquidy [ __ ] on my
carpet the other day a liquidy [ __ ] dude
like I had to clean it up it was so hard
to clean up because it was like picking
up that gak remember that [ __ ]
Nickelodeon gak remember that was a
little more watery than that though and
there was something in it I don't even
know what the [ __ ] was in it like it's
not even edible [ __ ] you know yeah and
people are like yeah but get organic dog
food yeah get organic dog food whatever
was in my dog [ __ ] was not an organic
dog food he'd they'll eat a [ __ ]
literally would eat up a condom like a
dog would eat a condom straight up 100%
all right cool let's do this Twitter
questions from you cooter baby at
turnaround cut gunk what about when
[ __ ] the sentence what about
when [ __ ] who put the long
European license plates on their car
[ __ ] off
congratulations give me this ISM yeah
you mean Europeans folks this guy
talking about do Americans can you do
that yeah but those are they didn't they
get throw a car imported and they just
didn't get our license plate yet that's
got to be that dude if you [ __ ] get
the European license plate on innama
it's gotta be illegal that's there's
long ass slices buddy you know how long
has got to be I was gonna be long as my
[ __ ] dude how long do those have to be
as long as my [ __ ] um oh that's a good
one and go back and go back producer one
fire Tracy Qi happy weird last name at
TR Jia P thoughts on side
preachers telling everyone they're all
going to hell yeah dude there's one a
guy on Hollywood and Highland that does
this and do this guy it's like you're
not changing anybody I would venture to
say did that guy's foot traffic is gotta
be thousands of people a day he's
literally not one person was like okay
I'll believe in Jesus you either believe
in Jesus or you don't in this guy repent
they're all talking about repent the day
is coming really when when's it coming
when salvation just buzz words repent
and salvation John 16 for they just say
numbers and [ __ ] has nothing to do with
the [ __ ] thing I could go out there
talk [ __ ] I know nothing about
religion John said in 14:6 that the day
was coming and to reckon upon thee with
great vengeance a that there's not even
sentences and people just walk by they
would even notice they'd just be like oh
yeah and I wouldn't change anybody's
mind get a better outlet if you're on
the street corner doing anything get a
better outlet get a blog dude
target [ __ ] your audience get a
Twitter you know what you shouldn't do
stand on a crate ever hey don't stand on
a crate hold a wooden stick with a
[ __ ] yellow poster board on the top
of it
written in the Sharpie at least get the
sign made do it better repent in the
Salvation Aristotle said in 12:9 Book of
Revelations don't be a coup de Jim said
I could even say names that aren't even
in the thing Tyler said in the book of
Genesis in the Tyler said in the book of
Sega Genesis
in verse nine chapter seven line twelve
the reckoning will come upon with a
fierce awakening and people will just
walk by and not know what the [ __ ] I was
saying here's mace at a scratch
when I was a baby I would catch Judas by
the way apostrophe s I don't like that
mistake dude when I was a baby I would
catch CUDA CUDA is Cudas now I'm a grown
man but still a baby telling CUDA is to
turn around turn around so this is a
baby a kid holding the CUDA a Barracuda
an actual Barracuda you need to redo
that picture right now dude how old you
are and hold the [ __ ] actual human
CUDA and put it back to back now that's
cool how about the apostrophe s's you
ever see that website that's like
there's a website out there that's like
missed it
' mistake by apostrophe or something and
it's like it shows all the [ __ ] signs
with the [ __ ] apostrophes there's
one in downtown LA I just saw drove by I
did a gig downtown and there's one that
was like something about jewelry
jewelry's and it had I said jewelry I
don't know something like that but it
had apostrophe s I'm so dumb whatever
huh here's from the right stuff at cool
kool-aid man five one eight right
what's with people who brush your teeth
at work I actually think that that's
good
if you're doing anything with personal
hygiene good people who are messy as
[ __ ] people are gross they're sweaty and
clammy and they have bad breath and they
have [ __ ] like crust and [ __ ]
wash up wash the [ __ ] up for brush your
teeth at home and only bring it out when
he's needed but like also you're
annoying if you just eat lunch and then
have to brush your teeth though
so like brush your teeth
every once in a while at work if you
need to but like don't be the guy that
does it every day then it's just like
you're a [ __ ] weirdo you're just like
some guy that's like or some girl that
like just takes it too far I know a
comedian that brings his own sheets to
[ __ ] well he's really successful now
but when he used to do gigs and stay at
the comedy condos he would [ __ ] bring
his own sheets which is like kind of
makes sense and I think about it because
it's so gross I mean there's so much
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] on those sheets
probably the comedy condos especially at
the lawyer Comedy Store one Jesus Christ
is probably got Sam Kinison scum on it
[Laughter]
you know what else maybe think of of the
[ __ ] was I just talking about to funk
I don't know
but the [ __ ] when people have big ass
water bottles or some people have that
like really big water bottle with like a
I handle on it dude go to a place to
fill up a smaller water bottle I mean
you know you can get a big [ __ ]
bottle with a handle buy another one you
[ __ ]
cheapskate big-ass [ __ ] with a
Crystal Geyser so big with a with a rope
handle some have a [ __ ] like a
plaster or a plastic milk gallon thing
of it some people have that and they
work out with that dude like fill it up
intermittently bring a little Arrowhead
water bottle and fill it up
intermittently you know if you're that
who think man Dahmer Dahmer era has a
funny bit about that [ __ ] who drinks
that much water about how doctors say
you got a drink [ __ ] eight to ten
gallons a day or whatever the [ __ ] it is
I'm not gonna [ __ ] try to I'll ruin
it but he so it's so funny but like who
drinks that much [ __ ] water at the
gym they got that [ __ ] gallon who
does that so annoying I don't know I
want to I want somebody to do that with
soda at the gym
or like a [ __ ] milkshake bring a huge
milkshake at the gym and just [ __ ]
drink it and it's so hard to drink it
and it's so [ __ ] thick do we got one
more question not that one before I get
out of this hot how did I get less hot
as we went on so here we go
Kabir upall @k underscore T at all tal
tal hey you need to stop using the [ __ ]
word uh-uh
111 what what is this [ __ ] guy even
saying hey you need to stop using the
[ __ ] word
100 percent of the time in your podcast
a 100 percent at a time so this guy's
not American obviously using the [ __ ]
word I mean no I won't i won't stop
using it i'll use it whenever I want and
also here's a hashtag not your mom
hashtag still it's true baby
hashtag commercials I'll tell you what
you're not a true baby if you tell them
the [ __ ] cult leader what to do
I mean you're out bro Kabir you're out
you're not a true baby see you you're
not at Kay underscore ta al you're out I
won't block you're anything but you just
out you're not coming to the cabin in
the woods that's that's that's as much
Sam that's as much that's
that much is true what's that mine
hunting is [ __ ] good man it was
really interesting did you watch it one
episode he shakes his head he's like
yeah it's really good he watches one
[ __ ] goddamn episode see this is why
one fire yeah you like the one episode
but you gotta watch the whole [ __ ]
thing to know if you like the whole
[ __ ] thing or not one fire shakes you
said oh yeah I love it
why'd you see one episode this 10 god
damn I saw someone [ __ ] said ten
percent of it the last two episodes are
great they're gonna make another season
I heard but yeah anyway
[Music]
yeah I'll say [ __ ] when it you know I
say [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] I want gotta
gotta got to talk the way you talk dude
you can't [ __ ] not talk the way you
don't talk
I remember when somebody said yeah but
you he's a teacher said yeah but if you
say you [ __ ] a lot your limited your
vocabulary huh if I don't say [ __ ] I'm
using one less word if I don't say [ __ ]
him using one last word
uh Zach Crampton add Zach Crampton
slacks or trousers the what the [ __ ] are
slacks what the [ __ ] are trousers meant
your goddamn British I tell you what if
you're American and you just asked me
that question move to Britain we'll
catch you later all right dude
it's hot we've done over an hour for you
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] how's that tall tall order the
how your name was so here we go new
shirts in the store no kuda is up you go
get it and did we put up the other one
the new one then there's a [ __ ] cool
one we did it's like a look got a
vintage look it's a it's a rock T a
metal rock T yeah it's very cool I can't
wait to get this [ __ ] thing
the metal shirt is in go get it and the
restock is in you got restocks they're
in we got no kuda shirts they're in
we've got metal shirts they're in
you can get metal shirts there in
subscribe rate and review the show
please do all this [ __ ] man
tweet me at congrats pod or use the
hashtag congratulations pod hope you're
enjoying the video episodes on youtube
video episodes go up on Tuesdays or
Wednesdays upcoming shows buy tickets on
Chris D'Elia calm Chris D'Elia calm
Columbus Ohio
Irvine California San Jose California
Riverside on New Year's Eve Riverside
California Winnipeg I added a second
show that's going the first one sold out
immediately calgary few tickets left man
on fire my special on Netflix watch it 3
watch it like it and thank you for
listening
and remember I don't know this you know
remember see you guys later
[Music]
you